just think about the matchup between
adam wainwright and whitmerfield
we know that adam throws a lot of off
speed with does a really good job of
fighting those things off the hyundai
pitch arsenal
for adam wainwright and he's got a whole
lot of pitches and uses all of
them to sinker the four seam the cutter
2-2
to center there's harrison bader and
there's one away
and silver out in front pops it up a
mile high on the infield
colton wong under it one two three for
the kansas city royals and the cardinals
coming up
and the cardinals will face matt harvey
the boys have been busy the last couple
of days 15
runs on 24 hits and matt harvey that's
an interesting look so far i'm still
getting used to seeing him in that
royals blue
and matt harvey got a lot of those in
his first two innings against the reds a
lot of called third strikes
with his fastball goldschmidt strikes
out on a breaking ball and matt harvey
has a one two three bottom of the first
with two strikeouts
ryan o'byrne got a breaking ball and
hits it to the gap
fowler cuts it off and ryan will hold
with a lead off single ah i didn't mean
to sound surprised he got a hit but it
was nice that we found a hole
so now the royals need a hit with a
runner in scoring position
and ryan mcgroom is at the plate
and he swings at the first pitch which
is rare he doesn't get a hit but he'll
get an rbi
the young throws him out ryan o'hearn
who opened the inning with a single
comes down from third and the royals
lead
one nothing stayed upstairs so with two
outs
and nobody on the royals get
back-to-back walks against wayne wright
and that'll bring up ryan o'hearn and he
swings at the first pitch and knocks it
into left field
coming around as dozier he will score as
the throw is to third solaire
is safe and the royals take a
two-nothing lead
carl set up base hit into center
sweet stroke right there dylan's
probably thinking to himself on that
pitch what was that
what was that thing is that a fastball
yeah i'll take a good swing at a
fastball this season with runners in
scoring position
edmond six for 15. and it's hit down the
right field line
it is a fair ball fair ball for tommy
edmond
and the cardinals with that double a
ground rule double for tommy edmond they
scored two and they've tied it up it's
2-2
runners at first and second miller
base heading to right edmond will score
goldschmidt on his way to third
and brad miller comes through and the
cardinals have their first lead of the
night and it's three to two
st louis and the young lines it
knocked down by franco from his knees
throws it away
goldsmith is scored miller to third
de young to second and the cardinals
have added to their lead
you are tough physically like he was
look at that
and just by putting the ball in play
he's safe
he forces a throwing air and he got
gallagher
over to third base and now he'll come
home on the air
so it wasn't textbook as far as getting
the ball
to the right side but he avoided the
strikeout and now it's 4-3 in the fifth
lifted in the air to dylan carlson
catch his main merryfield is tagging up
the throw into third edmond
applies the tag it's a double play
strong
throw coming in mirrorfield
testing the rookie and he picks up an
outfield assist
ryan's still looking for his first home
run and he definitely has
power here's the 3-1 a swing and a high
drive
right center field that's a way back
that ball
is going to be a goner
home run ryan o'hara ties the game
how about that we just talked about he
was looking for his first
and he hit a high arcing shot
that made it into the right center field
seats for dozier
walked and scored back in inning number
three was after the first pitch and
grounds it up the middle and into center
field so
a great start as dozier was ready for
gann's first pitch so the lead run is
adverse nobody out
so here we are eighth inning two on two
out the 4-4
tie and it's mcbroom
against john gant breaking ball stayed
up and that's grounded into left field
dozier rounds third here's the throw
from left it's not in time
throw down to second and wong
runs as hard as he can to get mcbroom
he didn't want to give franco the chance
to round third and score
but the royals take the lead on ryan
mcbroom second rbi of the night
and the 1-1 base hit into center
three-hit night for paul dion
so here is yachty grounded into a double
play a strikeout
and popped out into shallow left the
young the runner at first base
he is running and it's lifted to left
field
whit is back he turns and molina hits it
off the top of the wall
and with de young running he
is out at the plate the royals get an
out
at home plate as yachty or molina
just missed a home run and de young was
running on the pitch good turn i'm
saying oh
no that's going to go out watch the
relay throw
right to modesty who has a great arm who
perfectly won
hops it on the perfect side of the plate
to nail him
royals holding tight with their lead
with outstanding defense
and vader shoots and then the gap in
left center extra bases for bader
the cardinals will have the tying run
maybe at third
here comes another relay he is
safe at third a triple for bader
and the tying run at third and only one
out here in the bottom of the ninth
and a chopper hit out to monday he will
run to the bag
and the royals have even the series and
they have won their first game of the
year
trailing after five innings there you go